- ... et qu'il faudrait arrêter
de construire de nouvelles
centrales électriques.
- "J'aime Hydr v va célébrer
ses cinq ans.
(rire de Christine)
On a pu voir cette pièce-là
au théâtre, en balado,
toutes sortes de plateformes.
Bref, tout le monde au Québec,
je pense, a vu "J'aime Hydro".
Et dans cette ce-là, oui,
vous parlez d'hydroélectricité,
mais aussi vous parlez de votre
travail de comédienne. Ça vous
tenterait pas de faire une pièce
de théâe e e documentaire sur :
est-ce que les arts de la scène
sont un service essentiel?
CHRISTINE BEAULIEU, comédienne
- Ha! Oui, mets-en! Bon sujet!
C'est vrai que ça ferait un très
bon sujet. Vous êtes le premier
à m'apporter ça, mais ça serait
vraiment un bon sujet parce que
c'est une très bonne question
à se poser. Moi, je pense que
ce l'est, essentiel, la culture,
totalement. Je veux dire, en ce
moment, il nous manque ça, tous
ces lieux-là qui vibrent dans
une ville, partoààà travers
le Québec, où on requestionne la
société, on rebrasse les idées.
Dernièrement, justement, pour
"J'aime Hydro, 29 novembrededede
Brochu, la nouvelle PDG d'Hydro-
Québec. Et c'est elle-même,
d'entrée de jeu, dans
notre entrevue, qui m'a dit :
"Tu sais, les artistes, vous
êtes toujours 10 ans en avant
de votre société". Tu sais, elle
a commencé notre entrevue comme
ça. Puis, elle dit: "C'est
ce qui est merveilleux avec les
artistes, puis les créateurs.
Puis, vous nous obligez
à regarder en avant, puis
à réfléchir plus loin que
ce qu'on est parfois en train
de faire comme réflexion."
- Christine Beaulieu,
"L'oeil du cyclone".
- Je veux parler de "L'oeil
du cyclone" parce que vous avez
remporté un prix Gémeaux pour
votre rôle d'Isabelle, 39 ans,
mère célibataire,
mère de trois enfants.
- Puis, traite pas ta soeur
d'épaisse. Là, j'aimerais ça
qu u u u u un petit peu plus
concentré, les jumeaux!
- La deuxième saison débarque
sur ICI Tou.tv la semaine
prochaine la semaine prochaine,
le 3 février. Mais comment vous
l'avez étudié, ce personnage-là,
pour aussi bien le porter
à l'écran?
- En faijejejejeje n'ai pas
d'enfant, alors j'ai bien sûr
observé les femmes autour de moi
qui ont des enfants. J'ai deux
soeurs, moi. Elles sont
jumelles. Elles ont chacune deux
enfants. Puis, elles ressemblent
beaucoup à Isabelle Gagnon,
c'est-à-dire qu'elles vivent
comme ça aenenenenenenfants,
elles ont "full" de plaisir
aussi avec leurs enfants. Puis,
je pense qu'Isabelle, c'est ça.
Si elle a le choix entre aller
dans une "date" ou rester avec
ses enfants puis écouter un
film, tu sais, elle a vraiment
plus le goût de rester avec ses
enfants puis éfifififififilm!
(rire)
Ça fait que je me suis beaucoup
inspirée de mes soeurs,
franchement. Puis, mes soeurs
sont très proches de moi.
Donc, disons qu'Isabelle est
un mélange de mes soeurs,
de moi et de toutes mes amies
femmes qui ont des
Tu viens de t'installer ici
ou...
- Vous êtes soit chanceuse
ou très bonne parce que c'était
aussi excellent, la série
"Lâcher prise", et vous
incarniez Josiane, qui est
aussi un.......
- Oui.
- ... qui subit de la charge
mentale. Et je me disais :
comment vous voyez la charge
mentale chez la femme de 2022?
- Oui, bien, c'est ça, on entend
beaucoup parler de ça.
C'est que, en fait, les hommes
sont là, sont présents, il
pas non plus les oublier ou les
mettre de côté, mais souvent,
mes amies femmes qui ont des
enfants, qui ont une famille,
disent : "Tu sais, mon chum,
il veut aider, mais parfois,
les hommes ont pas le réflexe de
penser aux choses à l'avance."u,
l'homme et la femme, on est
différents, on a différentes
forces. Mais tu sais, donc,
toute la planification,
l'organisation, c'est souvent...
ça a souvent été dans la cour
des femmes de toute l'histoire
de l'humanité. Donc, je pense
qu'ichchchchchchchchose de
normal là. Puis là, aujourd'hui,
on est en train de constater ça
et on a besoin que ça change.
Tu sais, autant les hommes
que les femmes ont besoin que
ça change parce que maintenant,
la femme, elle travaille aussi.
Et tu sais, les choses ont
tellement évolué. Donc,
c'est un peu ça aussi,
"L'oeil du cyclone" montre
qu'on... il faut faire
des pas ensemble en société
à ce niveau-là.
- Depuisdudududududududu Cégep
de Saint-Hyacinthe en théâtre,
en 2003, vous avez joué
dans 28 séries télé, 22 films,
19 pièces de théâtre.- T'as pas?
(rires)
OK! Ayoye!
- Comment vous faites le choix,
puis comment vous faites
pour continuer à ce rythme-là?
- Écoutez, que ce soit
du théâtre, du cinéma ou
de la télé, j'aime vraiment
les trois mé
vraiment de préférence. Ça va
être l'équipe. J'ai-tu envie
de me rendre au travail pour
collaborer avec telle ou telle
personne? Est-ce que je vais
me sentir bien? Est-ce que... tu
sais, je vais être confortable
de... Tu sais, parce que
les acteurs, on jo
avec notre coeur. Tu sais,
il faut ouvrir, il faut être...
Pour jouer avec notre coeur,
il faut qu'on soit bien pour
laisser la porte ouverte.
Puis, si on es
tu sais, la porte se ferme
rapidement et je pense pas
qu'on va performer aussi bien.
Bref, on dirait que c'est ça
qui est devenu important pour
moi. C'est vraiment d'être bien
pour être capable de bien
performer. On dirait que si
je suis pas confortable, je sais
que je vais pas bien performer.
Donc, je dirais vraiment que les
humains avec qui je travaille,
maintenant, c'est rendu ça
qui est le plus important.
- Pendant la pandémie,
mais vous avez pas chômé. Vous
avez tourné da
qu'on va pouvoir voir en 2022.
Alors, Christine Beaulieu,
j'ai l'impression que
la prochaine année sera encore c